welcome to the man of recaps here to
announce new channel memberships I love
making these recaps for you but it takes
a ton of hard work and time if you love
my recaps and want to support the
channel hit that join button for just
three dollars a month you can be a recap
champion and seriously help keep the
channel going plus it comes with some
cool benefits you'll get Members Only
access to all my recaps a day early and
I'll keep you guys updated with Members
Only posts and polls about what I'm
working on and what I should be working
on next so if you can please hit that
join button it will seriously help me
bring you more of the best recaps of TV
and movies